Leslie Moonves remains chairman and CEO
of CBS after a board meeting amid a
sexual harassment investigation
the CBS Board of Directors which Moonves
Leeds met yesterday six women accused
Moonves of harassment and intimidation
in a New Yorker article last week
Moonves denies or says he doesn't recall
many of the details from the report Anna
Werner is following the company's
response and a good morning good morning
Anthony shares of CBS Corporation have
dropped 10% since Friday when the story
broke CBS s board has taken steps to
launch an independent investigation last
night that drew some commentary some
people asked me probably because I work
here what do you think is going to
happen I don't know on the late show
Stephen Colbert brought up the sexual
harassment allegations against his
company's CEO I like working for him but
accountability is meaningless unless
it's for everybody whether it's the
leader of a network or the leader of the
free world his comments came hours after
CBS's Board of Directors left their
meeting with Leslie Moonves still in
charge in a statement the company said
the board is in the process of selecting
outside counsel to conduct an
independent investigation but some
analysts questioned the board's actions
I cannot imagine a scenario where the
board comes out that says we support him
we're keeping him there I just can't
imagine it'll be hard for the network to
return to business as usual with Moonves
still in charge a source tells CBS News
when the board began discussing the
allegations against Moonves during the
meeting he stepped away The New Yorker
last week published the accounts of six
women who claimed he sexually harassed
them including four who say he forcibly
kissed or touched them all said their
careers suffered after they rejected his
advances Moonves acknowledges there were
times decades ago when he may have made
some women uncomfortable by making
advances but says he's always understood
no means no and that he's never misused
his position to harm or hinder anyone's
career
on her CBS showed the talk Moonves wife
Julie Chen reinforced comments she made
in a tweet on Friday saying Moonves is a
kind decent and moral human being and
that she fully supports her husband and
stands behind him now some of you may be
aware of what's been going on in my life
for the last few days I issued the
one-and-only statement I will ever make
on this topic on Twitter and I will
stand by that statement
Today Tomorrow forever women bezu is
alma mater Bucknell University is
distancing itself from him the
University removed all references to
Moonves from its website the CBS Board
of Directors also said yesterday its
postponing its annual shareholders
meeting that meeting was supposed to be
held August 10th Alex thanks Anna